Okay, let's look at the solution. What about optimized
app code? Well that's about making the code actually
run faster. App stats is the best option for
that. What about reduced latency for static content? Well doing
this would involve reducing the latency to the user.
A perfect example of edge caching. What about making your
app more responsive? Well, certainly queues could be an
option here to reduce the amount of time spent when
you process the request. But that could also
achieved using automatic scaling parameters, and of course mem
cache to serve content from memory instead of
datastore. What about reducing datastore reads? Well certainly, mem
cache would help out here, but edge caching
could also be an option if the content is
suitable for that. What about improving performance as
user base grows? Well, that's a clear cut scaling
out problem, so automatic scaling. All right, I hope you did well. And this quiz
has no exact answers. So be sure to discuss this in the forums as well.